Peter Baucom the platform lead at
Quizlet Inc said we believe GCP has
better core technology in particular
it's networking and disk technology
thanks Peter we really appreciate that a
huge component of why that may be is
Google's persistent disk persistent
disks are durable network storage
devices that your instances can access
like physical disks in a desktop or
server the data on each persistent disk
is distributed across several physical
disks compute engine manages the
physical disks and the data distribution
to ensure redundancy and optimize
performance for you
persistent disk offers multi reader
capability with multi reader mounting
many virtual machines can read data from
a single persistent disk with no
performance degradation multi reader
mounting makes sharing content a snap
this lab will take you about 30 minutes
to complete and you'll learn how to
create a virtual machine instance create
a new persistent disk attach persistent
disks to a virtual machine instance
format and mount the persistent disk and
automatically mount the disk on restart
persistent disks are located
independently from your virtual machine
instances so you can detach or move
persistent disks to keep your data even
after you delete your instances this is
the fifth lab in the GCP essentials
quest completing this quest earns you
this patch to recognize your achievement
next up hello node keeper Nettie's